one of the things that really upset me
for a long time was the fact that I had
great ideas and intentions and I wanted
to manifest them and I thought this is
how it's going to manifest and so I had
all these visions of how things were
going to unfold and then I'd started
processing it wouldn't unfold and then
it would irritate me because like I've
got to make it work I gotta make it work
ultimately I started to recognize when
things didn't work it was possibly
because there were better ways to do it
and I wasn't conscious of it and so what
I started to learn over a period of time
was simply this there's an old saying
there's a means to an end and the idea
well the end is your destination and of
course the means are how you're going to
get to that destination well of course
all of us sit down and say yeah this is
what I want and then we start to figure
out well this is what I'll do to get to
those ends I'll get to this and I'll get
to this to get to the end what I started
to realize at some point was maybe my
awareness of how to get to the end
wasn't exactly accurate and it turns out
many of the times when things didn't
work and I was like so upset it didn't
work but it turned out oh there was a
better way to get there and I didn't
even know it so the universe was really
facilitating me and I wasn't paying
attention I was getting angry at the
universe because like it's not working
in a way I want it to work and then I
started to realize some point was my God
maybe the universe has a better solution
than the one I was even thinking of
myself hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because the thing that
saved me as an entrepreneur was watching
the stories of other successful
entrepreneurs and I learned from their
advice I learned from their motivation
and honestly I have no idea where I
would be if I didn't have those videos
to inspire me I still need them for
myself today too and I hope that they
can inspire you as well so today let's
learn from one of the best Bruce Lipton
and how your thoughts create your
reality
enjoy
I really learned over a period of time
it's very critical insight to help me
get to where I am is to focus on them on
the end what is it I really want put
that Focus together and it's very
critical it's very interesting because a
lot of people have oh I would like this
and it's a broad General category and
then at some point it's like well it's
not specific enough you have to have to
actually say what it is you want I'll
always remember I was uh looking for a
special shirt to go to a Pink Floyd
concert and and I just all of a sudden
visualize oh it'd be neat to have a
Russian shirt you know with a collar
that goes across here and a couple of
buttons down and I thought oh yeah that
would be really great that would be cool
shirt and then I stopped and I was
thinking where the heck do you get a
shirt like that I have no idea in the
world but I thought that would be pretty
good so I figure well I still got to get
something so I drive off to a mall up
near San Francisco and I walk into the
mall and there's a first men's store
over there and I go let's start looking
I have no idea and I walk in and of
course there's this big circular rack of
sale clothes and I thought what the hell
it's only a Pink Floyd concert one night
let's see what's in there and I started
going through the wreck and lo and
behold oh my God a Russian shirt right
in the middle of everything and it was
like the shock of oh my God there's a
Russian shirt right here
the and for the unfortunate part of it
was I had the picture of a Russian shirt
I said cool
I never said what the color was or
anything else I just had Russian shirt
and there was a Russian shirt color gray
no color at all why I didn't put in the
concept of color and universe said well
just give it to them in Gray and it was
one of those things like oh be conscious
of what you're asking for because the
the more detail you put in
the more the universe can manifest a
resolution if you leave a lot of blanks
in what you want then all of a sudden
it's like well it's random whatever
fills in the blank because you never
said what you wanted you can have an
idea what you want and that's important
but the most important part of that just
having an idea is not just have a broad
idea I want X and I go no no what
exactly do you want why
go back to the principles of Science and
the principles of science reveal
something very important that principle
of science is this Consciousness is
creating our life experiences I go well
that sounds new agey I go no this is not
new Agee this is the primary principle
of quantum physics we are creators this
is a fact in fact uh quantum physics has
that but now let me add one other fact
epigenetics says the same thing because
epigenetics says your Consciousness is
controlling your behavior and your genes
and so it's time to stop for a second
and recognize where is your
Consciousness what are you thinking
about and the idea is start thinking all
those very positive thoughts but don't
try and tell the universe how it's going
to manifest okay you think of the
picture
let the universe get you there
and that's the most important lesson
I've learned I'm not telling the
universe how I'm going to get there I'm
just saying universe is where I want to
go
and then the universe will take care of
it it's so powerful it's so wonderful
and I never believed in it for the first
40 50 years of my life but I can tell
you now the life that I'm manifesting
today is a consequence of just what I
said focus on the end don't tell the
universe the means to get there rule
number two is break negative patterns
frequently a mass every day how come you
look so happy and the answer is I wake
up happy and why do I get this happiness
where is it coming from and the answer
is this it's another day on planet Earth
and what's so exciting about it is it's
another day that I have no idea what's
going to happen but the greatest wishes
and desires for some fun and excitement
and a very joyous life so I start off
with today's gonna be a great day and
almost every day it ends up being a
great day doesn't mean everything works
right but the beautiful part about it is
I've really learned not to to carry
anything forward that is not really
happy and enjoy Us in my life it reminds
me of a story two Buddhist monks are
walking along and Buddhist monks are not
allowed to touch women at all and these
two Buddhist monks are walking along
they come to a river and not that River
there's a woman dressed in her wedding
Refinery and she's crying and she's
crying because she can't get across the
river wearing these clothes so one of
the monks just picks her up carries her
across drops her off on the other side
then the two monks continue walking
and about an hour and a half down the
road one monk says to the other one how
could you pick up a woman
and the one who picked up the woman
looked at me and said I I dropped her
off an hour and a half ago why are you
still carrying her and the whole idea
about that is the meaning of it is when
events happen in our life it's not
necessary to keep carrying them
especially if they're negative ones you
can just stop right there and go on to
the next thing it's a choice do I want
to be in an environment where I'm not
happy or to want to be in an environment
where I am happy oh Choice well
obviously but most of us have that
choice but are so caught up in
conventional rules and conventional way
of mannerisms and social structure that
we hold ourselves in places we don't
even want to be and then we sit there in
our mind getting aggravated by the whole
factors I don't even want to be here and
I go well the guess what choice
pick a place you want to be go to the
movie go do something else
break the pattern
and when you break the pattern is your
moment of power because when the pattern
is broken there's new choices at that
moment but if you don't break the
pattern you're going to follow Litany of
up or down depending how you started off
the process the litany down not a great
trip I'll tell you that but hey I think
it's over 20 some years I haven't been
depressed I haven't even been angry
I get upset by some things of course but
it doesn't mean I hold them I drop that
person off on the other side of the
river and stop carrying it
and this is the choice it really is a
choice you have to think about it
because it's a conscious Awakening at a
moment that gives you a choice that
wakes up and goes do I want to do this
and that's that moment of choice you
take that moment of choice and then you
say I'm moving into where I want to go
you make a habit out of this because you
repeat this and then guess what you
don't even have to think about it
anymore because the subconscious program
will always redirect you to the place
you want to be and the whole other world
that we used to experience I used to
irritate us and aggravate us and all
that anxiety stuff
it just doesn't exist and it doesn't
mean everything's going right but the
whole beautiful part about it is well if
it doesn't go right okay stop now let's
go do something else because it's the
idea it didn't go right and then why
didn't go right and who didn't make it
right and where is it going to go now
and blah blah blah and what are you
doing you're digging a hole and it's not
going up it's going down
and the whole idea is choice but the
most important part of choices you have
to stop long enough not get caught up in
in the in the program and play out the
program there's a moment while you're
playing the program maybe you can
separate and look at yourself and say
why am I doing this because that is the
moment of power that is the moment where
you can say I have a choice I can do
something totally different than to Stew
in this stuff and then you are a
powerful person rule number three is be
the architect of your life well I've
been talking about the fact that
Consciousness is created in a world and
I say it's based on science well let me
give you a very important fact it was in
1927 in the founding of the science of
quantum physics that we get the most
important Insight from one of the
founding fathers of quantum physics Max
Planck and what does Max say all matter
originates and exists only by virtue of
a force we must assume behind that Force
the existence of a conscious and
intelligent mind
he concludes this mind
is the Matrix of all matter
well that was what 70 some more years
ago or 100 years ago I say has that
changed I go no look at this for example
this is an article out of the most
prestigious scientific journal on this
planet nature and I say what's this
article I said it's called the mental
Universe it's by a Quantum physicist at
Johns Hopkins University I'm not going
to go and describe it by everything he
says in the article because Richard Khan
Henry the author summed it up in the
last sentence let me emphasize for you
that last sentence in this article on
quantum physics
the universe is immaterial
it's mental and spiritual
live and enjoy well this has been the
constant truth of quantum physics since
the beginning and quantum physics is the
most valid of the Sciences in regard to
the theories actually predicting reality
so the significance is we have to do
something about our Consciousness now
I've been talking about that
Consciousness for a long time
finally medicine is actually just
beginning to see the light of this new
insight I'd like to read a quote from
you from Steve Cole a professor of
medicine University of California Los
Angeles
he wrote an article on poverty and the
genetics of health and I'd like to share
with you an excerpt out of this article
because for me it's so important that
I'm not the only one out there saying
this and in fact this is now becoming
part of mainstream medicine so what does
he say about this article in the answer
is simply this
quote
to an extent that immunologists and
psychologists rarely appreciate we are
architects of our own experience
but then he goes on to say your
subjective experience carries more power
than your objective situation
and I go well that sounds interesting
actually it's more than interest it's
most profound sentence I could read for
you and I go why well in a sentence he
talks about subjective experience I say
what is subjective experience it means
experience influenced by our feelings
our opinions and our beliefs
subjectivist what you think about
something
and then he goes on he said that the
subjective experiences carry more power
than your objective situation I go
objective situation what does that mean
the situation that is not influenced by
your personal feelings or opinions it's
just based on facts so now let's read it
replacing subjective with belief and
objective with reality now let's read
this sentence and it goes your belief
carries more power than your reality
this is the merging of quantum physics
and biomedical science coming together
they both agree it is through our
Consciousness that we are creating the
experiences we are having in our biology
and the behavior that we're experiencing
and manifesting in the world
and when we understand this and take it
from the awareness of the conscious mind
it says yes I I know that as a principle
I said yeah but we must take that belief
and put it into our subconscious program
because our life is coming 95 from the
subconscious
so if we don't take that belief and put
it in the subconscious the knowledge in
our conscious mind will have no
influence on our lives
we're in a state that says now we must
own this truth and walk this truth
in order to take us from today's world
into that future where that possible
heaven on Earth is available to everyone
on the planet at the same time not just
even the people the animals the birds
the insects in every other living form
is dependent on our Consciousness the
more people sharing the same
consciousness of a healthy happy
harmonious future the more people that
are thinking that the more broadcasts
the more tuning forks and they add up
because there's power the more people
sharing the same Consciousness the more
power that Consciousness has to manifest
itself and so all of a sudden I say well
what's Evolution all about I say each of
us is a participant
to create a consciousness
that represents our heaven on Earth
because the more people that share that
consciousness
the more the reality will manifest
heaven on Earth in that regard
life is a honeymoon also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is stop living in
fear looking at the world and seeing
what's going on right now all the
Curiosity of people that's going on is
so distressing at one level and it's
interesting for me because as a
scientist I can stand up and talk about
the fact that today's chaos is a
necessary requirement for the evolution
that we would love to see and yet I like
you have to live in this crazy world
it's mind-blowing it's crazy and it
becomes really important because all of
this stuff that we're hearing is
motivating fear and fear by its
definition is disempowering because when
you're in fear you're expressing I have
no power to take care of myself and we
give up power and we give it up to other
people to create the world for us and
obviously by looking at this computer
and watching what's going on around the
world those so-called leaders are not
really helping us get to the destination
of a heaven on Earth reality
and it's time to recognize yes fear
takes away our power I've talked about
that in many many lectures talked about
the fact that stress hormones actually
shut down our Consciousness and puts us
into a reactive mode
well this is not a time for reaction
it's a time for creation
and this is what the emphasis of quantum
physics has been telling us that our
Consciousness that is making creation
and yet if we're living in fear and
Consciousness is coming from Fear then
what world are we creating well that's
the chaos we observe every day on the
news so in this situation what we really
have to do is just listen to the words
of Franklin D Roosevelt when he said
the only thing we have to fear is fear
itself
also relevant today are the profound
words by Frank Herbert in Dune where he
says fear is the mind killer and this is
what we have to recognize rule number
five is change your thinking the
chemistry of your blood is controlled by
your brain I go yeah but what does that
mean I say and here's the most important
point the brain takes the picture in
your mind whatever it is and translates
that into complementary chemistry that
it puts into the blood and then that
environment of the blood now adjusts the
genetic to fit the picture that was in
your mind so if you open your eyes and
you see someone you love the chemistry
of the brain is oh yeah so much
beautiful stuff vasopressin makes you
more attractive you know oxytocin binds
you bonds you to that source of Love uh
you get pleasure chemicals out of there
and growth hormone I say so why I said
the chemist the chemical infusion of
blood from Love
it causes the cells to grow beautifully
that's why people when they fall in love
they glow it's like well you're healthy
I go yeah you're healthy because that
blood chemistry environment culture
medium is enhancing Your vitality and I
go but if you see a picture that scares
you a fear picture
you don't release love chemistry you
start to release stress hormones and
chemicals that shut off the immune
system in a protection mode I go oh wait
a minute then the cells are interpreting
the chemistry of the blood to adjust
themselves but the chemistry of the
blood is a reflection of the mind and
all of a sudden it's like um
we are controlling our genetics the
genetics don't control loss we control
it with the chemistry that we send and
all of a sudden it says then the picture
in your mind consciousness
is the director of your biology change
your Consciousness and your biology will
change automatically and people go oh
mind over matter I go for a hundred
years we've known that in medicine it's
called the placebo effect I give you
this pill it's going to heal you I tell
you it's the greatest thing from
medicine this is going to heal you I
give you the pill you get well then you
go the pill heals me and then it's a
sugar pill and I say then what healed
you and the answer is your belief in the
sugar pill and everyone goes yes
positive thinking placebo effect and I
go and what you've left out perhaps is
the most important part is that negative
thinking is equally powerful is positive
thinking but
it goes in the opposite direction while
positive thinking enhances life negative
thinking can cause you to die you just
have the belief you're going to die and
you will die
you can have the belief of any disease
and you can get any disease because the
mind is going to translate that belief
into the chemistry that manifests what
was in the mind so
um then the bottom line is
genes do not control Our lives our
Consciousness controls our lives and
when we change Consciousness we change
the character not just inside of our
body but the behavior that also
complements that picture and all of a
sudden it bottom line conclusion we're
not victims of our heredity we are the
masters of our biology but if you don't
know this and let your mind run wild
well then you can create anything and
unfortunately most of the thinking is
negative and this is why it was so
important that uh Deepak come out early
in the game and start giving people this
information because it was necessary at
this time for people to own their power
in creating life because if you claim
you're a victim the first thing you did
is you let go of power and now you have
no control over your life and Deepak
from day one was talking about this
nature of this Consciousness that's
involved in in my work led to the
mechanism where that Consciousness hits
the cell and boom biology on rule number
six the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is control your
energy the difference between coherence
and incoherence coherence means it's all
lined up together and incoherence is
energy is just so just to give you an
idea of what's the difference between
coherence and incoherence
if you take a 10 watt light bulb and
turn it on you're going to get a glow of
that light bulb it's not going to be
white light actually be sort of more
orangey yellow because it's not very
high voltage it's a low voltage and I go
wow so uh you can barely read you know a
book under that 10 watt lipo but then
here's what in a laser
you take those those uh energy and it's
those photons and instead of just like
dispersing them randomly like a light
bulb the light the photons are going off
in all directions simultaneously but I
said what if you make it coherent Ah
that's called a laser where all the
photons are there streaming down in a
narrow beam and I say if you take a 10
Watt
light bulb and make it coherent and at
least make it into a laser beam so all
the photons instead of randomly being
dispersed are all going down to the
narrow beam a 10 watt light bulb
the 10 watts and the laser will burn a
hole in your wall it is so powerful that
it'll melt your wall right in front of
you 10 watts and I go wow the same 10
watts that I could barely read by and I
say yeah now I say you know put that in
the body I say Y is irrelevant if my
energy my key isn't really totally
organized it's like a 10 watt light bulb
I'm hardly lighting up anything with my
energy
but if I learn how to exercise it's
really an exercise of causing flow in
the body the flow of the energy and the
more you practice the more it becomes
coherent and I say what's the relevance
about that if if you can mobilize this
energy and make it coherent my God you
become super powerful and this is where
all that uh you know Asian martial arts
stuff comes from is being able to focus
the energy and using it to empower and
healers can do this by using their hands
with focusing their energy their Chi
they can bring their hands up and put
energy into a system just like lasers
and heal somebody with that energy okay
or in a you know martial arts you can
use that energy to ward off an attack
and so the point about is this why are
you doing the exercises the answer is to
enhance your power and I say how do you
enhance your power because you start to
be able to control the flow of energy
and take it from an incoherent state
which has little power
but by making the flow and controlling
it then it's like controlling a stream
of energy and that's where the power
comes from the power and martial arts
fighting but the same power can be used
not just for for for finding but for
healing and that's uh the power of
what's going on through the hands of a
Healer because out of the Palms is a
port where the energy running through
your body can be elicited through your
hands and this is uh uh the result of
empowering Yourself by controlling the
energy
when we talk about how do we create
rituals or how do we change habits
that last
the first things to have a different
expectation than I'm going to change in
a day or a week or in 21 days whenever I
try to change anything
my number one rule is 100 days or I
don't even start
so if I want to let's say stop caffeine
it's a 100-day commitment
so first I make longer term commitments
and then I design a plan to retrain my
brain around the expectation of
following through I make pre-commitments
in advance so if I say let's say I'm
going to stop drinking coffee
I say okay I'm going to stop drinking
coffee I commit to it for 100 days and
then I write out well what will you do
in the morning when you wake up and you
want a coffee
what will you do when you're at a
restaurant with friends and everybody's
having a coffee what will you do so you
counter any of the behavior when you
know the trigger is going to happen
every habit has three parts to it
there's something that triggers the the
emotion there's the behavior and then
there's the neurological and biological
reward
so when you understand the Habit part of
any ritual you understand that because
we are conditioned a certain way we're
going to have a trigger whether it's a
flower whether it's waking up whether
it's a girl or a guy or or children
coming home it triggers a response in
the brain or reaction in the brain well
if we change the behavior over the
course of 100 days
will still get the reward
and if we pre-commit to what we're going
to do when we say ah maybe today I'll
have the coffee and tomorrow I won't uh
maybe today I'll have the pizza or the
dessert and I'll catch up tomorrow
well if you pre-commit in advance
that you're not going to take that
action
then that's step one step two is when
you have the trigger if you interrupt
the behavior for one or two or three or
four minutes you interrupt the neural
pattern in the brain also
so you come up with strategies is what I
feel like having a coffee or dessert or
the pizza or the croissant okay then
here's what I'm going to do instead
for five minutes
and that way I can interrupt the pattern
if you do that long enough
you'll start to develop a new neural
pattern you'll start to develop a new
behavior and if you do it for at least
you know 66 days but preferably a
hundred days you'll start to develop a
new way of thinking and being and doing
that will overshadow the other pattern
in the brain very interesting yeah so
there's there's a there's a a psychology
behind it but there's also the
neurological processes of the brain and
what happens is our brain doesn't like
change yeah so any time that there is
change the brain see it feels
uncomfortable as soon as it feels
uncomfortable it'll send signals to the
motor cortex of the brain it'll send
messages and we'll start to rationalize
we'll start to tell ourselves well I
shouldn't do it because of this well
maybe today is not a good day we'll all
start today you know but I won't
continue until next week or you know
what I really don't want this we start
to talk to ourselves and when we
understand what the brain does whenever
we try to change
then we can start being in control of
the brain and we can override the
automatic responses there's something
called automaticity
and automaticity
states that anything that I repeat over
and over and over again over a period of
time will go from conscious effort
deliberate conscious effort willpower or
persistence and it'll become automatic
so we just have to know how long that is
and some things take a week some things
take 60 days some habits that people
have for 20 30 40 50 years take 200 days
and so you start off with a hundred day
window and you ask yourself am I willing
to give a little bit of effort for 100
days to remove this destructive either
thought pattern or destructive
behavioral pattern in order for me to
have something greater and better than
what I have right now so it's very
important you you focus a lot on what
you will have or what you who you will
have who will be in the future to keep
your motivation yeah if you think about
this one of the best
examples that I ever came up with
is imagine if
I give you a Hollywood script right now
okay and I say to you
um if you learn this script
for the next six months
I will give you 10 million dollars
to be on stage to deliver that we're
going to film you and if you're amazing
you're gonna have a chance to win an
Academy Award
what will you do with the script
starting today
I start to learn I start to learn you
start to read it you start to
emotionalize it you start to practice it
you start to you start to do everything
possible to become
something that's in writing
something that came out of somebody's
head that they wrote a script for that
you don't have any idea what it is but
if you made a commitment to becoming
that person and you rehearsed it and
practiced it every day you wouldn't get
it right the first day or the first week
for the first months or the first month
but if you knew there was a big payday
emotionally spiritually financially and
that people would go to the theaters and
love to watch it and they'd laugh or cry
or be sad and be happy because you're
able to take them on a beautiful
emotional roller coaster ride
then you would become that role yeah
most people are interested
they're not committed and the difference
is when you're interested you do what's
convenient and what's easy but when
you're committed you do whatever it
takes
so can you repeat it sure when you're
interested you do what's easy and what's
convenient for you yeah but when you're
committed I'm gonna get that result
you put everything into it until you get
the result I want to start with two
questions that I really want you to
think about
and the two questions are
what should I be afraid of today
and who's to blame
[Music]
what should scare me and whose fault is
it
to me
these are the most
profoundly dangerous questions that we
Center our lives around
um and what they are indicators
to me with their indicators of is a
culture of scarcity
a culture of not enough
and when you think about think about any
milieu in your life think about
education what are we supposed to be
afraid of
and who's to blame
Politics the economy social issues
I guarantee you if you turn on the news
or open to paper today
the focus would be
here's why you should be afraid and
here's whose fault it is
and it
and what's interesting to me about that
is it's not just at a cultural level or
a community level that stuff happens in
my house every week
every week with my husband I talk to him
about what we should what should be you
know why we should be fearful and whose
fault it is mostly it's his
um
but you know if something doesn't go
well at my daughter's school
and I'm like oh my God
this is this is going to have huge
implications for our University
and we should be terrified right now
that she's not getting cursive I know
she's four
but this is still relevant it's
indicative of scarcity so let's talk
about what scarcity culture is
and what it looks like scarcity culture
I think is best understood with a simple
question of
never enough
and you can fill in the blanks never
good enough safe enough certain enough
perfect enough relevant enough and
perhaps I think one of the most
dangerous and Insidious messages today
is never extraordinary enough
somehow
[Music]
in the world we live in today
an ordinary life has become synonymous
with a meaningless life
and it has huge I mean and I've watched
it happen not only as a researcher I
mean a qualitative researcher so I sit
across from people and look in their
eyes and I have a good sense of what's
going on in their lives but as a
university Professor who's been teaching
for the last 17 years
it's been very clear to me that
extraordinary means relevant
and the top one is is the big one for
all of us personally never good enough
yeah which is shame which we all have on
occasion that since
that we're not smart enough good enough
perfect enough loved enough promoted
enough
we're not enough
so what we do in response to scarcity
culture I think all of us every day
is this
we wake up in the morning and we armor
up
and we we put it on and we say I'm going
to go out in the world
I'm basically just going to kick some
ass
I'm not going to let anyone see who I am
and in doing so I can protect myself
against the things that hurt the most
judgment criticism fear blame ridicule
I'm gonna armor up and I'm gonna be safe
and we rationalize and we convince
ourselves that this armor is really
smart
and we use a lot of different things to
armor too
perfectionism
intellectualizing
but if you get really really clear about
what we're doing every morning when we
wake up and decide to armor
it's this simple
this is what we're protecting
protecting
[Music]
being hurt
for a very simple reason
that no one really wants to talk about
which is This Love
belonging
irreducible needs of men women and
children
in the absence of love and belonging
there is always suffering
and so what we believe is that we can
protect our sense of being lovable
and being acceptable and being worth
connection
with armor
here's the very worst news from my
research
the news that above all other I did not
want to hear
is simply this and I don't even want to
say it to you because I think it's mean
to say it
but it's so true
and it's simply
our capacity
for wholeheartedness
can never be greater than our
willingness to be Brokenhearted
which is a terror a terrible thing
but a truthful thing
that we can only love and be loved
as much as we are willing to have our
heart broken
and so when we move through the world
like this and with our partners with our
children with our friends in classrooms
with the people who work for us with the
people we work for
there are tremendous casualties you must
visualize the steps that lead you
to the thing that you want
not the end goal this is a major mistake
that people make they manifest
improperly because all they do is focus
on the end goal if you've ever made a
vision board think about what you put on
the vision board you put up just the
beach house or the million dollars in
the bank are you crossing the Finish
Line are you launching that business are
you having the body that you want or you
would drive in the Maserati whatever it
is the end goal is what you put up on a
vision board that is not what you're
going to do when you manifest if you
start focusing on crossing the finish
line of the marathon that is a one-way
ticket to being unmotivated and
completely discouraged in fact research
shows that if all you do is focus on the
thing that you want and you just focus
on that vision of you and your bikini
body or you with the love of your life
on your arms or you at the Oscars
winning that award or the Grammys what
happens is because you've only focused
on the end goal you start to feel really
unmotivated and discouraged because
you're nowhere near it that's where
manifesting comes in because we're not
going to focus on the end goal you got
to pick something that you want in order
to get started but manifesting isn't
about the end it's about the bridge
it's about going from where you are here
to where you want to go
imagine that there is a bridge
that connects where you are right here
with what you dream about doing
now that dream could be to be a Grammy
award-winning
singer-songwriter that dream might be to
have a family of your own that dream
might be to have a beach house or a ski
house or to take a trip to Fiji that
dream can be whatever the hell you want
it to be but when it comes to
manifesting once you've given yourself
permission to dream with the lid off and
really want what you want to feel the
pull of that thing now we gotta talk
about the path that connects where you
are with where you want to go and this
is all about visualizing the Little
Steps there's a lot of research that
proves why visualizing the steps is the
most important thing that you could do
there was a study done at UCLA for
example where they were researching
manifestation and the power of
visualization and they broke students
into two groups and they had group a
we're going to call these the vision
board group they had group a closed
their eyes visualize in their mind and
feel in their body
themselves taking the test and then
walking up to a board where the tests
scores were posted and finding their
name and seeing an A plus that's what
group a the vision board group we're
told to do to visualize themselves
achieving what they wanted
Group B
we're going to call these the hard
workers these students were coached in
this research project to close their
eyes and to visualize going back to
their dorm room sitting down at the desk
and studying and staying up late and
putting in the work studying and
preparing for the tests
now let me ask you a question
which group do you think did better on
the actual test
was it group a the vision board group
who were taught to visualize and picture
themselves walking up to a board and
seeing the a plus
or was it Group B
the hard work group the group that was
taught to close their eyes and visualize
and seeing themselves doing the work to
study for the test
well if you answered group a you're
wrong
if you answered Group B you got the
correct answer the reason why Group B
the students who visualize studying for
the test got better test scores is
because when you visualize yourself
doing the work visualizing it leads you
to doing the work and it's only through
actions that you will get the result
that you want preparing your mind and
visualizing yourself doing it lowers
your resistance and leads to you taking
the action that's why manifesting works
you know the same is true in sports
there's all kinds of research in sports
psychology in fact our Olympic athletes
for the U.S Olympic team they hire
Sports psychologists who train our top
Olympic athletes particularly after
they've been injured in visualizing
themselves competing when you coach an
athlete to mentally rehearse every
single detail about going through the
competition you are training the mind
body and spirit to show up and dominate
this is particularly true for athletes
after they've been injured and they're
stepping back into competition if you've
been injured in competition you're
naturally going to feel anxious you're
naturally going to be nervous your brain
and nervous system circuitry is now
programmed with the intensity from that
injury the memory from the injury so of
course it's natural to bring that in to
your pre-competition feelings about it
right so manifestation properly remember
what it is manifesting is preparing your
mind body and spirit to do the work it's
aligning your mind body and spirit with
what you want it removes the obstacles
that would normally stop you which then
prepares and motivates you to take the
actions to succeed so in the case of
athletes who visualize themselves and
see themselves doing all the steps over
over and over they're removing the
nerves they're removing all the
programming related to the injury they
are preparing their mind body and spirit
to go in and freaking Dominate and so
are you and I hear this from so many
people Gabby I'm doing it all I'm
meditating I'm praying I'm setting
intentions creating vision boards but
I'm not manifesting one reason you're
not manifesting is because you don't
believe in what you're trying to
manifest
when you believe it you'll receive it
but if you don't believe it then you're
just trying pushing control and try to
make something happen that isn't fully
ingrained in your presence in your being
in your energy and so you have to do
your part to get into the belief system
of knowing that this is indeed something
you are worthy of so how do you get into
that grounded belief system create a
vision statement a statement that claims
that your desire is on the way that you
are worthy of what it is that you desire
ground yourself in that statement focus
on it and instead of focusing on the
outcome focus on the feeling of what it
is to believe and know that you are
worthy of your desire if you're wanting
to attract a romantic partner into your
life a vision statement could sound like
I believe I'm worthy of the love that I
desire where I believe that I am ready
to receive that romantic relationship in
the perfect time and Order say that
vision statement daily for at least 40
days get yourself grounded in the belief
you you have to believe it to receive it
the next reason you're not manifesting
because you're trying too hard
I'm sorry to say it but it's true the
more you push the more you control the
more you try the more you affirm the
more you vision board the more the more
the more the less you receive if you're
pushing and you're controlling and
you're trying to make something happen
if you are completely out of alignment
with the universe you're not aligned
with that freedom that presence of Love
The Art of allowing rather than doing
forcing making happen yeah we have to
show up for our life but we can't force
our dreams to become a reality so the
key here is to let go so here's your
message the secret to manifesting is to
forget what you think you need let it go
how do you let it go with this intention
thank you Universe for guiding me to
what is of the highest good for all when
you make it about the highest good and
not about what you think you need then
the universe can truly show up for you
you can relax and allow even more than
you could imagine to enter into your
life
and here's another reason that you're
not manifesting this is going to be
tough for you to hear
because you're not vibrating at the
right frequency
what do you mean well what I mean is
that you're leaning into the negative
you're judging a lot you're focusing on
scary things that make you so anxious
and you just keep focusing on them and
dwelling on them you're obsessed with
worrying you love to overthink things
look I understand that behavior more
than anyone could imagine I'm a
recovering Warrior I'm a recovering
anxious person I've been there I
understand that but when we are not in
that vibration that's relaxed released
at ease present
we're actually blocking our
manifestations because that low Vibe
energy is blocking our high Vibe
attracting power so what do you do focus
on the good stuff lean into the positive
look for Solutions rather than problems
stop yourself when you notice that
you're being judgmental or gossipy hang
out with people that make you feel good
do things that make you feel good lean
towards joy and you will be led
when you dwell in that energy of Joy the
universe will deliver so if you're not
attracting what you desire just relax
it's all good focus on these methods
notice when you're out of alignment and
come back to this video practice one of
these methods use these tools ground
yourself back into alignment believe it
to receive it feel good and it will come
to you naturally we have the power
within us to attract what we desire when
we allow our internal condition to
reflect what we want to attract on the
outside so make that your highest
priority I used to struggle a lot with
manifesting just the idea of it I would
watch videos on it and I didn't
understand what they were saying I
didn't I just didn't understand it
whether it's manifest in a lot of
attractions like what are they saying I
don't understand the words that are
coming out of your mouth and I would
rewind and watch again it's like I don't
get it I don't understand I don't I
don't understand and it seemed weird
silly not good enough for me to just sit
on a couch and think about money coming
into your wallet or whatever it was that
you're trying to manifest you got to go
do something that in law of attraction
you know action is at the end of
Attraction like you got to go off and
and do the work if that's been you if
you've been kind of struggling with
manifesting or Law of Attraction you
don't know how it makes sense you rewind
videos and it feels too woo-woo for you
let me uh let me let me explain it from
a different perspective and and maybe
it'll help at least this is what's
helped me the first thing that I
realized is
very scientific is from the reticular
activating systems as part of your brain
that decides what to pay attention to
and what to not pay attention to there
there are so many things that are
happening right now all around you that
you are not paying attention to most
things your brain filters out your the
job of the reticular activating system
you can go look it up Ras is to filter
out most things and only filter in the
things that you should care about so for
example
um you know what color are your socks
today what color is your underwear today
you know looking down this street and
you know I didn't know that there was a
pine tree here what are you paying
attention to as you look out the window
you're looking at the tree you're
looking at the the sign here you're
looking at the driveway you look at the
cuddle of the sky you're looking at the
house you look at the what material that
might be you're not looking at anything
again just too blurry you're still
looking at my face you're looking at my
car you're looking at the color of the
headrest you're looking at my outfit
like what are you paying attention to
most things you're ignoring
because there's no possible way to pay
attention to everything potential to the
dog just Anna hello good girl
right we're ignoring most things because
it wouldn't serve you it's just
impossible to be information overload if
you feel like you're overloaded already
just imagine if you took in absolutely
everything so your eyes are bringing it
in and your brain is filtering out most
of it so what does your brain actually
pay attention to well the reticular
activating system
will choose to say okay you've set an
intention right I want to pay attention
to X and now all of a sudden you're
going to see that more often I I'm I
just bought a house so in that process
we started paying attention a lot more
to houses so one of the things I noticed
was the for sale sign here where I may
have not noticed that as much in the
past but because thinking house boom now
I'm paying attention to the for sale
sign you ever notice when you buy a car
you start seeing that car everywhere
right or even thinking about buying a
car you're thinking about buying an X
you start seeing it on the street more
often
why that's your reticular activating
system basically saying I want to pay
attention to those things so that car
was still around right I mean I I got
this car we've got a Porsche and now I
see Porsches more often those Porsches
still existed they were they were
already there I just didn't notice them
before and now I notice them because I
have one right
um so whatever it is that you want
whatever it is that you're setting
attention towards it's not just sit on
your couch and meditate and imagine
money coming into your wallet or a new
car or new house or business growth are
you speaking on stage or whatever your
goals are right it's not just
sitting on it and visualizing it but
it's noticing it and the elements of it
in your environment that when you start
thinking about it right we are we we
consistently think about when you start
thinking about it you'll start seeing
opportunities around you that were
already there
you just filtered it out because you
didn't see how it connected
now your brain's starting to make those
connections does that make sense
reticular activating system you're
ignoring most things
but when you set intention on the thing
that matters to you you'll start seeing
it in your environment and opportunities
for that to happen a lot more often so
that's step number one reticular
activating system it's the science
number two is to trust your intuition
more one of the things that really
helped me back early on in my career was
I
judge myself too harshly for the ideas
that I came up with and as soon as I
came up with an idea I was like oh you
can't do that or I had to have the
perfect Plan before I would ever take
any kind of action on it and you know
just later realize that you can never
plan all the way out there's no way you
know if you wait till you have the
perfect plan by the time you start
actually executing the plan is is dead
it's over
um and so you have to trust in your
ideas and so the thing that really
helped me is
I believe that great ideas flow through
me believe the great ideas flow through
you this is how you shortcut them your
brain that's designed to keep you safe
that's how you show cut the brain out of
the equation
you came up with an idea as long as it's
in you're in a positive state of mind
you're trying to serve right it's not I
want to I want to go you're you're in a
jealous Rage or you're angry don't trust
your ideas then but when when you're
positive and optimistic and bold and
courageous and an idea comes to you
trust that that's the right idea for you
just trust it it's a write it and then
go do something about it where normally
what we do is we overthink and we over
plan we over prepare and then we lose
the momentum and then the next day and
the next week or the next month it's
gone it's over it's like oh I can't do
that no that was actually a great idea
for you and it's happened enough to me
uh where those things have worked out
where I come up with an idea
and it doesn't make any sense
logically but I just decide to listen to
it and do something on it and it leads
to something amazing
the amount of times that has happened
is
pretty overwhelming
and so when you have enough repetition
for me I had to see it you know I had to
see it enough times come up because I
wouldn't just believe it on faith I had
to see it happen enough times and you
could test it yourself what ideas in
your head what big idea that you want to
do even a small idea what's what's
flowing through your head when you're in
a positive State you know put on a happy
song move around a little bit and then
notice your thoughts and where it's
going and what you want to create or who
you want to reach out to what you want
to do like what what thought comes to
mind after you're moving around and
having some positive energy that's
probably the right thing for you and
just test it out by doing something
about it and maybe that's a business
idea maybe that's an email you need to
send maybe that's a friend you need to
reach out to maybe that's an act of
kindness that you need to do whatever
the thing is that pops into your mind
trust those ideas and and you could be a
scientist like I'm I like data and I
like science and I like just I like
proving things
maybe I'm a skeptic I don't know but in
running those experiments I I proved to
myself that yeah great ideas do flow
through me
and so the next time I have a great idea
I'm gonna go and take action on it so
number one reticular activating system
it's already in your environment you're
just ignoring it but if you put
attention towards you start seeing it
like you notice a new car when you buy
your new car you see that car everywhere
and then number two is trust a good
ideas flow through you
number three is the one that I'm working
on that I'm I'm having the hardest time
with and I I believe it and I'm trying
to I'm in the process of getting better
at it is
when you're thinking about creating
something to talk to yourself in the
present moment
and this is something that
a lot of the manifestation a lot of
Attraction people talk about but also
people like Grant Cardone talk about it
uh that is it's not just
the people who would associate with it
but other people have had a lot of
success what you're talking about
whatever thing is that you want that
it's that it's already happened that
it's not going to happen in the future
but that it's already happened you know
if your goal is to speak on stage then
you're visualizing and you're telling
yourself I I am I am on stage I am
speaking to
I am speaking to a million people or
that's that's a that's a giant Stadium
I am speaking uh 70 000 people you know
I am I am the author of a best-selling
book uh I am like whatever your goal is
and what I think the point of that is is
yes one to see yourself accomplishing
big things uh two to not have a be so
far away that it lets you off the hook
for taking action but I think most
importantly is for you to feel what it
feels like to be that and the more you
feel like it feels like to be that the
more it actually becomes true if your
goal is to speak on stage in front of 5
000 people
and you actually
feel like you're doing it you can
visualize yourself being on stage and
doing it
the goal I think I'm still working
through this so one and two I've got
down three is my progress and my journey
so sharing with you
if you feel like you're doing it
if you are on stage and there's 5 000
people clapping for you and cheering you
you just gave the best speech you know
of your life so far
and you feel what it feels like to walk
off that stage and
what a gift that you gave people
that the more comfortable you get with
that feeling
the more it's going to be you and the
more that's going to show up does that
make sense so whatever it is that you
are trying to accomplish
whoever it is that you're trying to be
whatever your big goals are
that you imagine yourself already having
done it
and this is probably not something that
I would tell other people you know like
oh yeah I'm a I'm a you know I'm a
speaker in front of 70 000 people
[Music]
that big
but to yourself at least
to say it to see it to feel it to do it
if you're trying to heal yourself like
okay I am I am healthy
but but look I've got I've got a belly
or I've got a you know whatever I'm I'm
I am healthy I am healthy and and
visualizing yourself being healthy
because you want the feeling of what it
feels like to be healthy and the more
you feel like you are healthy and you
capture that feeling the more frequently
you're in there the more likely it's
going to show up
so that's probably not the most
articulate way to share it and I'm still
working my way through it as well so as
I keep getting better and keep learning
I'll keep sharing with you but
I used to think like manifestation law
of attraction was way out there stuff
that that I judged and that I didn't
understand and that didn't make any
sense like just go off and take action
guys and
with time and experience and exposure
and practice
um using the reticular activating system
to notice things around me by trusting
that great ideas flow through me and
following through and building momentum
and by talking to myself in the present
moment as if I am that person that I
want to become so I can capture that
feeling and know what it feels like to
be that person
I've shifted and seen some pretty
amazing results in my life in business
and I hope it can work for you too
learning to create our minds the way we
want is the basis of creating the world
the way we want
there is a wonderful story in the yogic
lore
on a certain day a man took a walk he
went for a long walk
accidentally unawares he walked into
Paradise fortunate isn't he
just took a walk and he landed up in
Paradise
after this long walk he felt
little tired
so he thought oh I'm tired I wish I
could rest somewhere
he looked around there there was a nice
tree
underneath which there was very cushiony
grass
so it was inviting he went and put his
head down there and slept
after a few hours he woke up
well rested and he thought oh I am well
rested
I'm feeling hungry I wish I had
something to eat
and he thought about all the nice things
that he ever wanted to eat in his life
and instantly all those things appeared
in front of him
you need to understand they have the
services like that
[Music]
don't ask questions
food came and he ate
stomach became full then he thought
oh my stomach is full I wish I had
something to drink
[Music]
all the nice things that he ever wanted
to drink
he thought about it and all of them just
appeared
drinking people also don't ask questions
so he drank
now with a little bit of alcohol in him
you know Charles Darwin told you all of
you are monkeys your tail fell away not
me Charles Darwin told you that you were
all monkeys and your tail fell away and
then you became human yes definitely the
tail fell away but the monkey
in yoga we always refer to an
unestablished mind
as murkata which means a monkey
why we are referring to the Mind as a
monkey is
what are the qualities of a monkey
one thing about a monkey is it's
unnecessary moment
[Music]
and another thing about the monkey is
if I say you're monkeying somebody what
does it mean imitation
monkey and imitation have become
synonymous
so these two essential qualities of a
monkey are very much the qualities of an
unestablished mind unnecessary moment
you don't have to learn it from the
monkey you can teach it to the monkey
and imitation is full-time job of the
Mind
so when these two qualities are on a
mind is referred to as a monkey
so this monkey became active within him
he just looked around thought what the
hell is happening here
I asked for food food came
I asked for drink drink came
there must be ghosts around here
and ghosts came
oh the ghosts have come they are going
to surround me and torture me he thought
immediately the ghosts surrounded him
and started torturing him
then he started screaming in pain and
said oh they're going to kill me and he
died
just now he said he's a fortunate being
the problem is he was sitting under a
kalpa rickshaw or a wishing tree
he asked for food food came he asked for
drink drink came he asked for ghosts
ghost came he asked for torture torture
came he asked for death death happened
now don't go looking for these kalpa
rukshas in the forest you can barely
find a tree
these days
a well-established mind
a mind which is in a state of samyukti
is referred to as a cultivation
if you organize your mind to a certain
level of organization
it in turn organizes the whole system
your body your emotion your energies
everything gets organized in the
direction
once all these four dimensions of you
your physical body your mind your
emotion and the fundamental life
energies are organized in One Direction
once you are like this
anything that you wish happens without
even lifting a little finger actually
it would help to assist it with activity
but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want if you
organize these four dimensions
in One Direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain period
of time
right now the problem with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction
it is like you want to travel somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction the question of you
reaching the destination is very remote
unless it happens by chance
so organizing our minds and in turn
organizing the whole system
and these four basic dimensions of who
you are right now in One Direction if
you do this you are a kalpa ruksha
yourself
anything that you wish will happen
but right now if you look at your lives
everything that you have wished for till
now if it happens you're finished
everything and everybody that you have
desired for if all of that lands up in
your house today could you live with
that
once we're empowered like this it's very
important that our physical action
emotional action mental action and
energy actions are controlled and
properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive right now that is our
problem the technology which is supposed
to make our life beautiful and easy has
become the source of all the problem
that we are destroying the very basis of
our life which is the planet
so what should have been a boon we are
making a curse out of it
what has brought incredible
levels of comfort and convenience to us
in the last
100 years or so has also become a threat
to our life simply because we are not
conscious action we are in a compulsive
state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means moving from a compulsive state of
activity to a conscious state of
activity
you might have heard of people
for whom they ask for something and
beyond all expectations it came true to
the true for them
generally this happens to people who are
in faith
now let's say you want to build a house
if you start thinking oh I want to build
a house to build a house I need 50 lakhs
but I have only 50 rupees in my pocket
not possible not possible not possible
the moment you say not possible you are
also saying I don't want it
so on one level you're creating a desire
that you want something on another level
you're saying I don't want it so in this
conflict it may not happen
someone who has some faith in a God or
in a temple or whatever
who is how simple-minded Faith Works
only for those people who are
simple-minded thinking people people who
are too much thinking for them it never
works a childlike person
who has a simple faith in his God or his
Temple or whatever
he goes to the temple and says Shiva I
want a house I don't know how you must
make it for me
now in his mind there are no negative
thoughts will it happen will it not
happen is it possible is it not possible
these things are completely removed by
the simple Act of Faith
now he believes Shiva will do it for him
and it will happen
[Music]
so is Shiva going to come and build your
house no I want you to understand God
will not lift his little finger for you
what you refer to as God is the source
of creation
as a Creator he has done a phenomenal
job there's no question about it could
you think of a better creation than this
is it in anybody's imagination to think
anything better than what is there right
now
so as a Creator he has done his job
wonderfully well
but if you want life to happen the way
you want it because right now the very
Crux of your happiness and your
well-being is this
if at all if you're unhappy
the only and only reason why you're
unhappy is life is not happening the way
you think it should happen
that's all it is
so if life is not happening the way you
think it is it should happen you're
unhappy if life happens the way you
think it should happen you are happy
it's as simple as that
so if life has to happen the way you
think it should happen first of all
how you think
with how much Focus you think how much
stability is there in your thought and
how much reverberance is there in the
thought process will determine whether
your thought will become a reality or is
it just an empty thought
or
how you do not create any impediments
for your thought by creating negative
thought process
this possible
is something possible or not possible is
destroying Humanity
what is possible and not possible is not
your business it's Nature's business
your business is just to strive but what
you want
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to reprogram your subconscious mind
with Bruce Lipton check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there you don't deserve that who do you
think you are young man the child under
seven isn't thinking oh I'm not doing
well but I'll do better and my father
will be happy I say no child under seven
not thinking recording